[Music]  when I thought of him I was they in a  way I wasn't when I wasn't thinking of  him I could remember who I was  by remembering him we are doctors we are  here to help the window  you try it some sleep I'm not tired  it is Laurie no you can leave at any  time it is not until you can't leave  that you can no  what are we doing yet with your help in  dirt we're not helping don't die on  yourself like everyone else here that's  not you  you don't even call me okay  you realize that really was  [Music]  I know that I will see you again I will  look out over the desert and I will say  your name  [Music]  and I will see your face his mother she  died my son has not spoken since he's so  terrible too